und jetzt das heute
journal 1990 eine magische Nacht und ein
gedankenversunkener Mann auf dem
Höhepunkt seiner
Karriere in diesem Moment se sein ganz
Leben an ihm vorbeigeflogen hat er
später
erzählt ein Leben das gestern zu Ende
ging guten Abend zum heute journal die
Nachricht dass Franz Beckenbauer
gestorben ist berührt auch Menschen die
mit Fußball nicht so viel am Hut haben
Beckenbauer der Franz der Kaiser war in
seinen besten Zeiten größer als Fußball
für Deutschland wohl das was pel für
Brasilien war eine Legende als
Lichtgestalt wird er oft bezeichnet eine
Lichtgestalt die aber auch
Schattenseiten hatte in Erinnerung
bleiben wird Franz Beckenbauer felen
wohl vor allem so wie er sich selbst
einmal beschrieb als ein Glückskind in
dem alle Sonntage vereint sein und für
den deutschen Fußball war er ein
Glücksfall Ariston selli und Ralf
panitck zeichnen sein
Lebensbild mit ihm kommt die
Leichtigkeit auf den Platz ein Tänzer am
Ball der schint mühelos spielt ein
Libero als Gestalter Franz Beckenbauer
prägt den Fußball verändert
ihn aus diesem proledensport Fußballs
einst Mal wurde ein
Gesellschaftsspiel und in diese Zeit bin
ich hinein geboren und habe versucht
mein Bestes zu geben Franz Beckenbauer
ist aber auch Arbeiter Kämpfer Antreiber
Stratege geboren am 11 September 1945
wächst in München Giesing auf früh fängt
er mit dem Fußball an wird gefördert
erwechselt mit 18 zu den Bayern in
München ist Teil einer jungen Mannschaft
die Trainerfuchs ciktschikowski
formt
1966 wemle Stadion mit 20 sein erstes WM
Piel England siegt aber Franz
Beckenbauers Stern steigt auf seiner
großen Enttäuschung über Platz 2 folgt
weltweiter Anerkennung und eher aus
Zufall wird wenige Zeit später bei einem
prtermin aus dem Fußballer Franz
Beckenbauer der
Kaiser als Libero spielt er sich und
seine Mannschaften zu Weltruhm vor allem
mit dem FC Bayern gewinnt er Titel um
Titel auch mit der Nationalmannschaft
sein größter als Sportler der
Weltmeistertitel unter den vielen
höchstbegabten RAG 1974 einer als
größter heraus Franz Beckenbauer als
Kaiser wechselt er dann nach New York
spielt mit P da ist er der Bayer aus
einfachen Verhältnissen schon längst
Weltmann und dort spätestens dort wird
er zur Kunstfigur der Fußball aber
bleibt seiner Heimat Beckenbauer
übernimmt 1984 als Teamchef weil er
keinen Trainerschein hat die
Nationalmannschaft die in einer Krise
steckt mit harter Arbeit die wieder
leichter herkommt formt er ein Team das
1990 in Italien Weltmeister wird und der
prägt das Bild dieser WM ja ich wurde do
von allen Seiten angequatscht und ich
wollte eigentlich meine Ruhe haben und
dann gedacht den einzigen die einzige
Platz wo frei war und wo ich meine Ruhe
hatte war auf ein Platz Spielfeld die WM
2006 kommt nach Deutschland vor allem
durch ihn Franz Beckenbauer ist Chef der
heimwm die so locker und leichter
herkommt wie er selbst er ist das
Gesicht einer WM die Deutschland und
sein Bild in der Welt verändert doch
2014 ziehen dunkle Wolken auf die FIFA
sperrt Beckenbauer wegen Unklarheiten
bei den WM vergaben an Russland und
Qatar auch ist vom gekauften
Sommermärchen 2006 die Rede von
Steuerhinterziehung Franz Beckenbauer
wird schwer herzkrank lebt zuletzt
zurückgezogen und doch bleibt das Bild
das ihn immer ausgezeichnet hat Franz
Beckenbauer der liebero mit großer
Leichtigkeit und wir sind verbunden mit
einem der profiliertesten Beobachter
Analytiker Kenner der Fußballwelt mit M
reif guten Abend Herr
reif guten ab große Fußballer die gab
und gibt es ja hier zu durchaus mehrere
auch Sieger aber keiner wurde der Kaiser
was hat Franz Beckenbauer so besonders
hervorgehoben aus ihrer
Sicht na ja Kaiser war schon als Spieler
weil er ein sehr majestätisches
auftreten hatte auf dem Platz das sah
alles sehr leicht sehr majestätisch aus
aber nach seiner Spielerkarriere hat er
ja weitere wir haben es ja vorhin gerade
gehört weltweit beachtete einzigartige
Erfolge eingeheimst also das ist alleine
jetzt jetzt mal nur das was er auf dem
Konto hatte und dann ich habe ihn ja
privat ein bisschen kennenlernen dürfen
jemand der so hoch fliegt der Gott
gleich zu einer Lichtgestalt gemacht
wird wird ist der dann aus solcher Höhe
abstürzt und davor aber immer Mensch
bleibt der wusste immer wo er her kam
der das da wurde auch nicht müde das zu
betonen der war der Junge aus Gesing
hier einem Stadtteil von München und ich
habe den nie abgehoben nie arrogant
gesehen nie nie von oben herab Menschen
gegenüber der hat
der konnte nicht nein sagen der hat kein
interviewwunsch AB ausgeschlagen der hat
keinen Autogrammwunsch ausgeschlagen der
hat ich habe ihn nie nie nie abgehoben
gesehen und das habe ich immer bis zum
Schluss bewundert und der hatte eine
Leichtigkeit eben auch beim Spiel also
eigentlich in vieler Hinsicht so gar
nicht so diese typisch preußischen
Tugenden oder der typische
Fußballspieler als der auftrat hatte das
auch damit zu tun dass er sowas ja
weltbürgerliches oder vielleicht auch
manchm ein bisschen künstlerisches an
sich
hatte ja das war ehrlich gesagt ein
bisschen sehr undeutsch auch zumindest
für den für die Art Fußball die damals
gespielt wurde zu seiner Zeit und da
ging er dann auch nach New York als
Fußballspieler und und war dort auch
sofort ein ein Weltstar und hatte keine
Probleme damit weil er der er blieb sich
ja immer immer treu er blieb der der
Franz wie gesagt der Junge aus Giesing
der in die Welt hinauszog der Dinge
konnte die andere nicht konnten der
daraus aber nicht eine große Geschichte
gemacht hat sondern der hatte Spaß am
fußballpielen und das hat er so
vermittelt und das gab diese
Leichtigkeit ja das war sehr undeutsch
und sprachen sie eben schon davon so
wollte man sein so wollte man gerne sein
aber träumte vielleicht nur davon oder
auch in dieser Zeit nun sprachen sie
eben davon dass er auch einen Absturz
erlebt hat also da waren die unschönen
Äußerungen zu Qatar da waren die
Bestechungsvorwürfe sogar Vorwürfe von
Käuflichkeit denken Sie das dass diese
ja doch in vieler Hinsicht einzigartige
Karriere langfristig überschatten wird
oder wird das irgendwann in
Vergessenheit
geraten die die die entweder oder sehe
ich nicht das das wird bleiben es ist
nichts nachgewiesen worden bis heute
insofern er hat unter diesen Vorwürfen
sehr gelitten vor allem weil sie so
zielgerichtet auf ihn gemünzt waren und
es waren viele viele Leute um ihn herum
die sich gern in dem Erfolg damals rund
um die WM 2006 haben die dann aber
schnell in Deckung gegangen sind und h
in seinem im Schatten dieser
Lichtgestalt sich ein bisschen wegducken
wollten Franz mach du doch sagt dass du
alles gekauft hast und dann ist doch
alles gut das hat ihn sehr sehr sehr
getroffen das wird natürlich wird da ein
ein Schatten bleiben aber dieses Märchen
ist ja nicht ich habe immer mal gelesen
von das das schmutzige oder beschmutzte
Sommermärchen ein Sommermärchen war es
aber und mir war vieles vieles Heuchelei
in dieser Zeit und diese hat ihn in ihn
getroffen das äh bleibt so er hatte ein
zu weinen ein sehr loses lose Art Dinge
zu Weg zu zu erzählen z.B die Äußerung
zu Katar ähm aber so war deswegen das
die die die hundertprozentige
gottgestalt wurde er zu der wurde er
gemacht aber das kann kein Mensch
leisten insofern ähm es wird einiges an
an Schatten bleiben aber ich glaube am
Ende werden viele die große deutsche
Lust verspürt haben am Denkmal stürzen
vielleicht jetzt ein bisschen
nachdenklicher werden und ein bisschen
kulanter im Urteil Erinnerungen und
Einschätzungen von Master reif danke ihn
für das
Interview sehr
gern nach dem heute journal Update
nachher um 0 Uhr sendet das ZDF noch ein
ausführliches Lebensbild von Franz
Beckenbauer und natürlich ist auch die
vorhin gesendete 45minütige Doku
jederzeit Zeit in der Mediathek
abrufbar der Tag begann heute für viele
mit dem knattern von Traktoren und
langen Staus unter Mittwoch will auch
noch die lockführergewerkschaft GDL die
Bahn bestreiken das kann also noch
heiter werden diese Woche wie viel
Sympathie die Bauern bei ihren Aktionen
begleitet wird unter anderem davon
abhängen ob es dem Verband gelingt Stil
und Ausmaß der Proteste zu steuern für
extremistenfahnen und Parolen oder einen
Mob der die ferienfähre eines Ministers
zu stürmen versucht dafür braucht
niemand Verständnis zu haben auf der
anderen Seite gibt es in der
Landwirtschaft handfeste Probleme die
weit über dieselsubventionen hinausgehen
und über die gesprochen werden muss und
das wollen wir gleich mit einem Experten
tun im Sinne einer Versachlichung in
aufgeheizten Zeiten zunächst berichten
Christiane Hoffmann und Laura
BIK
plakativ mit unter populistisch so der
Massenprotest der Bauern heute
Existenzängste trieben ztausende auf die
Straßen nicht nur in Berlin sondern
bundesweit auch in Mainz rollten die
Traktoren längst richtet sich ihr
Protest nicht mehr nur gegen die
Streichung der Subventionen für
Agrardiesel man kommt einfach nicht mehr
zum Atmen und irgendwo hat man das
Gefühl man wird erdrosselt und jetzt ist
der Punkt erreicht einfach mal zu sagen
halt stopp jetzt müsst ihr uns mal
zuhören sonst gibt's uns bald nicht mehr
was die Politik hier macht ist kurzatmig
ist stückwertig Stückwerk und verfolgt
keine wirkliche Strategie wie man dieses
Land und das Land und die Landwirtschaft
die Ernährung die regionale Ernährung
wirklich sicherstellen will im Norden an
der
A24 aber auch im Osten Westen und Süden
kamen schon früher Morgen tausende
Bauern mit ihren Traktoren zu
Sternfahrten in große Städte und
blockierten
Autobahnzufahrten zwar hat die Regierung
ihre Kürzungspläne geändert und es
bleibt bei der Kfz Steuer Befreiung für
Landmaschinen doch die Bauern halten an
ihrer Protestwoche fest Unterstützung
für sie kommt von einigen
Ministerpräsidenten man hat den
Landwirten diese Streichung vor den Latz
geknallt in einer Situation in der wir
Jahrzehnte von Strukturwandel hinter uns
haben die Bundesregierung zeigt
Verständnis für die Proteste bleibt aber
bei der schrittweisen Streichung der
Subvention
das ist unser Vorschlag und ich glaube
dass er auch richtig und abgewogen ist
niemand sollte sich Illusion machen es
schreiben sich gut viele seitenfüllende
Leitartikel über die Notwendigkeit von
Subventionsabbau aber jeder kleine
Schritt wird dazu führen dass man viele
Stimmen hört die sagen aber nicht diese
und ich glaube wenn das die Haltung wird
werden wir niemals irgendeine Subvention
abbauen die existenzgen der Bauern
versuchen einige rechte Gruppen und auch
die AFD in Schwerin Dresden und
Stuttgart zu Kern die Bauern wehren sich
dagegen gerade in den sozialen Medien
wird seit Wochen von einem Generalstreik
gesprochen es wird davon gesprochen das
Land lahm zu legen die Regierung zu
stürzen jetzt bricht die neue Zeit an
heißt es dort das kommt vor allem aus
rechtsextremer Ecke wird systematisch
betrieben teilweise in einer wirklich
für die nutzerinen auch nicht
durchschaubaren Art und Weise was sind
bauernproteste was ist Desinformation
wenn wir denen das den nähboden
entziehen wollen dann ist es nicht
anders als bei Republikanern DVU oder
bei der NPD man muss die Probleme klären
die aus Sicht der Betroffenen dafür
sorgen dass sie Protest wählen die
Bauern Proteste sie gehen weit über die
aktuellen Sparpläne hinaus und sollen
die gesamte Woche
dauern darüber wollen wir mit einem
Experten sprechen der und weder die Bau
noch die Regierung vertritt sondern
wissenschaftlich auf diese Branche
schaut mit Professor Thomas Herzfeld vom
Leibnitz Institut für agrarentwicklung
in
transformationsökonomien in Halle guten
Abend Herr Professor
Herzfeld guten Abend fraulomker wenn man
sich dann so die Parolen und den Ärger
dieser Tage bei den Bauern anguckt dann
könnte man meinen da geht's jetzt um
Leben oder Tod bei dieser
dieselsubventionierung aber das alleine
kann es ja nun eigentlich nicht sein
woran Wohl und Wehe von Höfen hängt
oder nein ganz richtig der die
agrardieselvergütung ist nur ein relativ
kleiner Teil der Subventionen die
insgesamt in die Landwirtschaft fließen
und es zeigt sich für mich viel mehr
dass hier ein aufgestauter Verdruss sich
bahnbricht der eben durch eine längere
Vorgeschichte hat und ein Teil davon ist
dass eben die Landwirtschaft in einem
recht unsicheren Umfeld operiert und
sehr oft durch die Politik eben neue
Vorgaben zum Teil auch eben sehr
plötzlich um die Ecke kommen nun gab es
ja eigentlich bemühen daran auch was zu
ändern es gab diese berühmte Borchard
Kommission benannt nach einem früheren
Landwirtschaftsminister die wurde noch
unter Angela Merkel eingesetzt da wurden
ganz viele Vorschläge erarbeitet den
auch alle Seiten zustimmten auch die
Landwirte z.B beim Thema Tierhaltung
Tierwohl was ist denn daraus eigentlich
geworden warum wird das nicht
umgesetzt es wird teilweise umgesetzt
das Bundeslandwirtschaftsministerium hat
ein Programm aufgelegt was aber eben die
Umbau der Tier Haltung zu mehr
tierwohlgerechten Stellen fördern soll
das aber finanziell mit sehr wenig
Mitteln ausgestattet ist dann auch nur
über 4er Jahre laufen soll und das ist
für landwirtschaftliche Unternehmen die
ein Stall eben wie gesagt 20 30 Jahre
nutzen müssen damit sich diese
Investition rentiert einfach zu kurz und
zu unsicher nun gibt es ja bei den
anderen Unternehmen also auch
Landwirtschaft sind Unternehmen das ist
klar aber bei anderen Unternehmen gibt's
ja auch eigentlich immer die Möglichkeit
Kosten und die ein stehen über die
Preise an die Verbraucher weiterzugeben
an die Kundschaft weiterzugeben das
scheint aber hier zu Lande bei der
Landwirtschaft oder gesamt in Europa
äußerst schwierig zu sein ja Sie können
sich das vorstellen wir haben knapp
200.000 Betriebe landwirtschaftliche
Betriebe in Deutschland und nur vier
fünf große Supermarktketten und diese
haben
eindeutig viel mehr Einfluss auf die
Preisgestaltung als die einzelnen
Unternehmen in der Landwirtschaft dem
was entgegensetzen könnten hier wäre
eine Möglichkeit dass die Unternehmen
eben stärker kooperieren im Rahmen von
Erzeugergemeinschaften oder
absatzgenossenschaften oder dass es
vielleicht eine Steuer gibt und diese
Vorschläge gibt's ja auch z.B extra
Steuer auf
Fleisch beim Fleisch ist richtig da
könnte der Umbau unterstützt werden
durch fiskalische Maßnahmen also eine
Steuer auf Fleisch oder aus
klimaolitischen Gesichtspunkten eine
Besteuerung von Produkten die eben
stärker zu klimarelevanten Mission
beitragen das sind aber wieder zwei
verschiedene Dinge und auch da haben wir
dann wieder ein sehr starkes staatliches
Eingreifen was nicht unbedingt die
Stellung der Landwirtschaft der
landwirtschaftlichen Unternehmen in der
Preisgestaltung stärkt das Problem dass
da sehr viel stat ist haben wir in der
Landwirtschaft her Professor Herzfeld
danke ih erstmal für das
Gespräch gern
geschehen das Interview haben wir vor
einer Stunde geführt dass sich
politische Gruppen wie etwa die AFD den
Frust unter Bäuerinnen und Bauern zu
Nutze machen wollen ist kein neues
Phänomen und zum Teil gelingt das ja
wohl auch ein solches wutpotenzial gibt
es aber offenkundig viele Orts bei den
bauernprotesten wird es nur gerade
besonders sichtbar unzufriedene
einzusammeln die sich von den anderen
Parteien nicht vertreten fühlen ist aber
nicht nur Ziel der AFD sie hat
Konkurrenz bekommen etwa durch die
Freien Wähler die in Bayern erfolgreich
sind und nun kommt noch eine neue hinzu
wenn auch mit altbekannten Gesichtern
das Bündnis Sarah Wagenknecht als Partei
heute in Berlin formell gegründet
darüber berichtet Andrea
Maucher schon am Morgen treffen sich 44
Gründungsmitglieder in einem Hotel in
Berlin die Frau die der Partei den Namen
gibt unterschreibt die Gründungsurkunde
und Deutschland hat eine neue Partei
zumindest wir alle glaube ich sind in
der Überzeugung hier dass wir heute den
Grundstein für eine Partei legen die das
Potenzial hat das bundesdeutsche
parteienspekum grundlegend zu verändern
dann macht sich die frisch gewählte
Parteichefin auf den Weg zur
Pressekonferenz durch eine Hauptstadt
voller bauernproteste es ist eine
Stimmungslage die sich Wagenknecht und
ihre Mitstreiter auch zu Nutze machen
wollen ein
antiampelprotest der Bauernaufstand
zeigt wie groß der Druck im Kessel in
Deutschland ist mit jeder Woche in der
diese Regierung Deutschland führt
verliert unser Land und Europa auf Jahre
hinaus die Zukunft Fabio demasi
ehemaliger linker Europa und
Bundestagsabgeordneter im kumex und
wecard Skandal einer der schärfsten
Kritiker von Olaf Scholz wird einer der
beiden BSW Spitzenkandidaten für die
Europawahl der andere Thomas Geisel
früherer SPD Oberbürgermeister von
Düsseldorf der sich von seiner Partei
abgewendet hat einen harten
migrationskurs fordert das individuelle
Recht auf Asyl in Frage stellt man muss
nur einfach sagen das individuelle
Grundrecht auf Asyl ist kein geeignetes
Instrument weil es tatsächlich die Tür
öffnet für eine unkontrollierte
Zuwanderung es ist ein politisches
Programm das sich nicht eindeutig
verordnen lässt rechter migrationskurs
soziale Wirtschaftspolitik das BSW lehnt
Sanktionen gegen Russland ab
positioniert sich gegen die NATO fordert
höhere Reallöhne links sein wollen sie
nicht mehr für viele Menschen ist links
ja heutzutage mit ganz anderen Debatten
besetzt da geht es um genderfagen da
geht es um Lifestyle Fragen und davon
fühlen sie sich nicht mehr vertreten und
deswegen werden wir diese Labels nicht
für uns benutzen das BSW wird wohl nicht
die einzige neue Partei bleiben auch der
Chef der rechtskonservativen werteunion
Maßen will eine Partei gründen der
grundimpuls zumindest ist der gleiche
dass es überhaupt so viele Intentionen
auf Neugründungen gibt egal wie die dann
am Ende ausg zeigt natürlich auch die
Unzufriedenheit mit dem bisherigen
Parteienspektrum natürlich baut man
darauf dass im Grunde ja auch diese
Unzufriedenheit
anhält weil davon profitiert man ja und
will man ja profitieren bei den Wahlen
selbst also meinesachens genügt es nicht
weil man muss ja dann auch deutlich
machen wo sind eigentlich die
Unterschiede zu den anderen Parteien die
auch protestieren das Parteienspektrum
wird sich in diesem Jahr aufsplittern
Wagenknecht selbst wird für die Partei
die ihren Namen trägt
2024 bei keinen Wahlen
antreten und mit dem vorhin schon
angesprochenen Bahnstreik geht es bei
dir jetzt weiter Heinz ja die Deutsche
Bahn ist zunächst mit dem Versuch
gescheitert den geplanten Streik der
Gewerkschaft deutscher Lokomotivführer
mit juristischen Mitteln zu stoppen das
Arbeitsgericht Frankfurt lehnte am Abend
eine einstweilige Verfügung gegen die
GDL ab die Bahn kündigte an in Berufung
zu gehen und die Entscheidung vor dem
häsischen landesarbeit Gericht
überprüfen zu lassen die GDL hat ihre
Mitglieder aufgerufen von Mittwoch 2 Uhr
bis Freitag 18 Uhr die Arbeit
niederzulegen bei DB Cargo soll die
Arbeitsniederlegung demnach schon morgen
um 18 Uhr
beginnen in Frankreich ist
Premierministerin bum zurückgetreten
hintergrund ist offenbar das jüngst
verabschiedete migrationsgesetz das
schlüsselvorhaben von Präsident macron
ging nur mit großen Schwierigkeiten
durchs Parlament Baum war seit mit Mitte
Mai
2022 Premierministerin wen Präsident
macron für die Nachfolge BS benennen
will und wann die neue Regierung steht
ist noch nicht
bekannt in Deutschland haben im
vergangenen Jahr rund
329 000 Menschen einen Erstantrag auf
Asyl gestellt etwa 50% mehr als im
Vorjahr wie das Bundesamt für Migration
und Flüchtlinge in Nürnberg mitteilte
die meisten Asylanträge stammten von
Menschen aus Syrien die mehr als eine
Million Flüchtlinge aus der Ukraine die
seit Kriegsbeginn Ende Februar 2022 nach
Deutschland kamen sind in der aktuellen
Statistik nicht erfasst da sie kein Asyl
beantragen müssen Bundeskanzler Scholz
hat andere EU-Länder aufgefordert ihre
Militärhilfe für die Ukraine
aufzustocken die bisher geplanten
Waffenlieferungen sein zu gering sagte
Scholz bei einem Treffen mit dem
luxemburgischen Premierminister in
Berlin russland hat heute wieder
dutzenden Marschflugkörpern und drohen
die Ukraine angegriffen mindestens vier
Zivilisten kamen ums Leben Ziel waren
der Osten und Süden des Landes frontnahe
Regionen sind weniger gut durch
Flugabwehr
geschützt und in dem anderen Krieg der
die Welt in Atem hält im Nahen Osten gab
es heute wieder intensive
reisediplomatie der amerikanische
Außenminister ist seit Freitag in der
Region heute führte er Gespräche in
saudiarab
parallel dazu ist auch die deutsche
Außenministerin unterwegs mit mehreren
Stationen heute war berburg im
Westjordanland Deutschland und die USA
eint die Sorge vor einer Ausweitung des
Krieges Michael bberunge
berichtet Aussteigen aus der gepanzerten
Limousine und Einsteigen in die
ungeschützte Welt der Palästinenser die
deutsche Außenministerin balanciert bei
ihrem nahostbesuch zwischen den Welten
abseits des Krieges in Gaza leiden die
Menschen im Westjordanland unter der
Gewalt jüdischer Siedler Einwohner des
Dorfes almasra alkabilia berichten aus
ihrem
Alltag nicht erst seit dem 7 Oktober
kommen die Siedler auf unsere Felder und
werfen Steine beleidigen uns sie hindern
uns unser Land zu bearbeiten und unser
Gemüse zu
ernten bbock verurteilt den illegalen
Siedlungsbau wählt harsche Worte
wohlwissend dass die schon in der
Vergangenheit vom Adressaten ignoriert
wurden es ist die Verantwortung der
israelischen Armee die palästinenserinn
und Palästinenser vor gewaltsamen
Siedlern zu schützen es ist die
Verantwortung der israelischen Regierung
bei Angriffen auf Menschen die hier
legitim wohnen und illegal angegriffen
werden den Rechtsstaat umzusetzen und
durchzusetzen und doch verdrängt der
Krieg in Gaza alle anderen Themen beim
palästinensischen Außenminister geht es
auch um die Frage der
Nachkriegsordnung Deutschland will wie
USA eine dauerhafte Besatzung durch
Israel verhindern die Autonomiebehörde
soll Gaza wieder regieren auch wenn die
als korrupt gilt und ohne Legitimation
durch Wahlen sie muss sich sicher
substantiell reformieren aber was wäre
die Alternative ohne sie eine
reformierte Autonomiebehörde ist
die gewaltfreie Alternative zur
Hamas unter der Gewalt der
palästinensischen Hamas leidet umgekehrt
Israel auf dem sogenannten Platz der
Geiseln stellt sich bärbock den
Angehörigen der Verschleppten mit denen
die Hammers ein grausames Spiel treibt
auch an einer anderen Front wird die
Lage immer bedrohlicher im Norden tötete
Israels Luftwaffe gezielt einen Anführer
der hzbollah Israel ist deren ständiger
Angriffe leid doch so könnte die Lage
weiter eskalier
wir haben der hesbollah gezeigt was
ihren Freunden im Süden passiert droht
Netanyahu in Anspielung auf Gaza das
wird auch hier im Norden passieren auf
berbock folgt am Abend US Außenminister
blinken Staffelübergabe beim Versuch den
Brand im pulverfassner Ost zu
löschen und jetzt geht's noch mal be
Heinz weiter mit Wirtschaft die
EU-Kommission hat eine deutsche Beihilfe
für ein großes Industrieprojekt in
Schleswigholstein genehmigt es geht um
viel Geld und um Batterien für
Elektrofahrzeuge welche Bedeutung hat
dieses Projekt Frank betmann eine nicht
zu unterschätzende Subventionen in Höhe
von über 900 Millionen Euro die werden
nicht mal ebenso durchgewunken sondern
Brüssel gibt deswegen grünes Licht für
deutsche Fördermittel weil man damit
strategische Ziele verfolgt nämlich bei
Technologien wie Halbleitern und
Batterien unabhängiger von Asien zu
werden insofern hat die heutige Zusage
Richtung weisen Charakter auch für
weitere gigafabriken in Europa in
Schleswig-Holstein will der schwedische
Konzern northwold nun jährlich
Batteriezellen für 800.000 bis zu einer
Million E-Autos herstellen losgehen soll
es wenn nichts mehr dazwischen kommt ab
2026 3000 Arbeitsplätze sollen entstehen
plus mögliche weitere für den Fall dass
sich weitere Zulieferer im Umfeld
ansiedeln für schlitwig-holstein ist es
schon jetzt das größte in
industrievorhaben seit Jahrzehnten ist
damit nun alles klar oder gibt es
weitere Hürden na ja die EU hat jetzt
zwar zugestimmt final hängt der Bau nun
aber tatsächlich von der Zustimmung
zweier Nachbargemeinden ab auf derem
Gemeindegebiet soll die Fabrik nämlich
entstehen ein Selbstläufer so hört man
sei das nicht das letzte Wort haben also
Lokalpolitiker Frank betmann vielen
Dank die Sternsinger bundesweit gehen
sie von Haus zu Haus überbringen den
Segen und hoffen auf Spenden so auch
heute im Kanzleramt der Hausherr empfing
108 Kinder und Jugendliche aus allen 27
deutschen Bistümern stellvertretend für
hundertausende Sternsinger die sich
bundesweit an der Aktion beteiligen in
diesem Jahr sammeln sie spenden für den
Erhalt des Amazonas
Regenwaldes kurz nach dem Start der
ersten privaten Mondmission hat es dem
usunternehmen zufolge technische
Probleme gegeben am Morgen hob die
unbemannte Trägerrakete vom
weltraumzentrum Cape Canaveral ab damit
ist zum ersten Mal seit 50 Jahren wieder
ein usraumfahrzeug Richtung Mond
gestartet die Störung führe aktuell zu
einem kritischen treibstoffverlust und
könnte die Mission gefährden so das
Unternehmen der geplante Termin für die
Landung auf dem Mond der 23
Februar das war's von uns gleich nach
dem dem Wetter geht's erstmal mit dem
montagskino weiter auf
[Musik]
Wiedersehen schönen guten Abend und
herzlich willkommen zum Wetter die Tiefs
sind derzeit auf anderen Bahnen
unterwegs z.B am Mittelmeer entlang
weiter nach Osten denn bei uns herrscht
hoher Luftdruck und da haben die Tiefs
keine Chance es gibt aber sehr wenige
Wolken in der kommende Nacht
dementsprechend wird es eisigkalt im
Norden funkeln die Sterne auch nach
Süden hin Richtung schleswi-holstein ist
es mal dichter durch Nebel ansonsten
herrscht ein ziemlich unangenehmer
Ostwind der ist auch noch böhig
Temperaturen dazu im strengen
Frostbereich mit
-15° teilweise oder häufig im Osten
zweistellige Minuswerte ganz im Westen
sind sie einstellig -3 z.
Richtung Nordsee morgen gibt es viel
Sonnenschein aber weiterhin unangenehmer
Ostwind der böig ist ja und ansonsten
ganz im Süden mal dichter bewirkt oder
Richtung Ostsee aber oft zeigt sich die
Sonne bei höchsten Temperaturen von -6°
nach Osten hin 0° z.B ganz im Westen
oder 1° Plus an der Nordsee aber man
sieht häufig es wird Dauer frostig kalt
bleiben die nächsten Tage viel Sonn
Schein ist dabei Mittwoch weiter in
eisig -3 bis + 2° das sind die
Höchstwerte Donnerstag dann weiterer
sonnschein -2 bis 4° und Freitag kommt
ganz im Norden Regen auf und es gibt
eine leichte frostabschwächung und damit
einen schönen Abend